In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 26th, on which we commemorate the Holy Haramarder
Ermolaus and those with Him.
On the 26th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Haramarder Ermolaus and
his companions Ermipus and Ermokratis.
These holy and glorious martyrs were priests in Nicomedia during the persecutions under Galerius
Maximian.
They were able to escape death by hiding in a house when the tyrant ordered that twenty
thousand Christians be burned in their church on the day of the Nativity, and they then
continued their apostolic work.
And Saint Pantelemon was arrested and brought before the Emperor, the latter asked him
who had instructed him in the Christian faith.
The saint, unable to lie, replied that the priest Ermolaus had been his teacher and spiritual
father.
Soldiers were immediately sent in search of the Holy Priest, whom they found and arrested
in the company of Saint Ermipus and Ermokratis.
When brought before the tribunal, they confessed Christ as the only true God who became incarnate
for our salvation and ridiculed the lifeless idols and all who worshipped them.
An earthquake then shook the city, and the Emperor said to the saints that it was a sign
of the anger of the gods.
They replied to him, how can fallen statues be gods?
At once men came to inform the tyrant that the idols had fallen down because of the earth
tremor.
Beside himself with rage, Maximian had Pantelemon thrown into prison and ordered the immediate
beheading of Ermolaus and his companions.
Thus they carried off the victors' crown, preceding their disciple by a short space into
the heavenly habitations.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.